དེ་ཚོ་ར། ཤེས་ཡ་རེད།
ཤེས་ཡ་ལབ་ན་དེ་ཚོ་ཀློག་ཡ།
རྐང་ཤུབ་གཅིག་ག་ནས་བུད་རེད།
སྣབ་ཕྱིས། ཨ་ཕ་སྣབ་ཕྱིས་སྤྲད་རོགས་གནང་།
ད་ཡིན་ད། སྒྲུང་དེབ་ཀློག་ཁང་།
སྒྲུང་དེབ་ཀློག་ཁང་ལབ་ཡིན།
དེབ།
ཤོག་གུ་རེད།
ད་དུང་གཅིག་དགོས། དགོས།
འདི་ག་རེ་རེད་འདུག འདི་ག་རེ་རེད་འདུག་འདི། འདི་ག་རེ་རེད།
འདི་ག་རེ་རེད་འདུག སྡོག་སྡོག་ཆེན་པོ་གཅིག་འདུག
ཝ་ཡེ། སྡོག་སྡོག་ཆེན་པོ་མགོ་སྒང་ལ་སླེབས་སོང་།
རྡོ་ཆེན་པོ། སྡོག་སྡོག་ཆེན་པོ་མེ་མོ་ཊ་མེ་སྒང་ལ་མར་ཟག་རེད་(ད)།མེ་མང་པོ་ཞེ་བོ་རག་སོང་ད།
ལབ་རེད་(ད)།
ད་ཡིན་ད།
དེ་རིང་ར། ང་གཅིག་སྒྲུང་ཀློག་དགོས།
དེ་རིང་སྲུ་མོ་དེས་གཡར་༼འཇོག་༽དེ་ར་ཁོ་རང་འདུག་སེ་རྡོ་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།ལྟ་ཨ། ངས་བསྟན་དགོས།
འདི་རྡོ་སྒང་ལ་འདུག་ག ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར་ཁོ་རང་བྱེ་མ་ལེབ་འདི་ཚོ།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་རང་ཁོ་རང་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)་མར་སྒང་ནས་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།དཀར་པོ་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།ནག་པོ་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།
རིལ་རིལ་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།དང་པོ་གཅིག་འདི་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར།
གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།གཡག་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།རི་བོང་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་ཆེན་པོ་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།བྱེ་མ་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།
ཁོ་གཉིས་ར། སྤང་སྒང་ལ་ར་༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་གཉིས་ནང་ལ་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར་ཁོང་གཉིས་ནང་ལ་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།
ད་ར།
ར། དང་པོ་ནས་ར་རྟ་ཆེན་པོ་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།
རྟ་ར་༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར།
འདི་བཤད་ཚར་ར། འདི་བཤད་ཚར་ར། འདི་ཡི་བཤད་ཚར་ར།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ག་རེ་བཤད་དགོས་རེད། ག་རེ་བཤད་དགོས་རེད། དེ་སྒྲུང་གཅིག་འདི་ནང་ལ་བླུག་དགོས།
ནང་ལོགས་ཚང་མ་འདི་ནང་ལ་བླུགས་དགོས། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽འདི་ནང་ལ་བླུག
ད་ད་དུང་གཅིག་ལབ་དགོས། ད་ཡིན་ད། ད་ཡིན་(ད་)དེབ་གཅིག
མི་དགོས་བས། འདི་དགོས་བས། འདི་མ་རེད་(ད)།ཁོ་རང་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ཡ་འདི་རེད་(ད)།ཁོ་རང་ལེན་གི་འདུག
ང་ལ་ཆུང་ང་ཡོད། ཨ་ཚ་ད།
ད་ར་སྒྲུང་བཤད་ཚར་རེད་(ད)།གཉིས་ཆ་སྒྲུང་བཤད་ཚར་རེད་(ད)།སྲུང་མོ་དང་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།
རྐང་པ་ཕལ་བཞག་རོགས་གནང་།
ཡ་གནང་རོགས་གནང་།
ང་baby ལ་ར། རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ཡ་མང་པོ་ཡོད་(ད)། ཁྱེད་རང་ནང་ལ་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ཡ་མང་པོ་ཡོད་བས།
དེབ་དགོས་བས།
ད་ཡིན་ད། baby ཁྲིད།
སྒྲུང་དེབ་ཀློག་དུས་ལབ་ཡིན། སྒྲུང་དེབ་ཀློག སྒྲུང་དེབ་ཀློག་དུས།
ཝེ་ཡེ། སྒྲུང་དེབ་ཀློག་ཐུབ་གི་ཡོད་བས་ལབ་ཡིན།
ཨ་ར། རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ནས་ཡར་སླེབས་ཡིན་ད། དང་པོ་ཨ་ར།
དང་པོ་ཡིན་ད། ད་ཡིན་ད། སྒྲུང་དེབ་ཀློག་གི སྒྲུང་དེབ་ཀློག་གི་ལབ་ཡིན།
སྒྲུང་དེབ་ཀློག་གི མ་རེད་(ད)།སྒྲུང་དེབ་ཀློག་གི
སྒྲུང་དེབ་ཀློག་གི་ལབ་ན་འདི་རེད་འདུག་ག་༼ཨ་ནས༽།
དང་པོ་བཤད་ད། དང་པོ་བཤད་ད།
དང་པོ་བཤད་(ད་)དང་པོ། ཨ་རྡོ་ལབ་ན་གས་མ་རེད་(ད)།
གི་གི་སུ།